so like all right let's go i want to
talk about
before you went into the ecstasy
business you were
huge in the stock market you were making
millions of dollars
you know buying and selling and uh
executing stock options
what is a stock option compared to these
bets on companies like gamestock failing
when they bet on a company failing like
this and how does it work
okay so let me just say that what i'm
about to say i need to do a disclaimer
now because there's laws against giving
investment advice
so this is just going to be educational
information
i'm going to give based on my experience
in the stock market from age 14
so i have what 10 20 36
37 years experience in the stock market
i was trading options in my late
teens and in my 20s i was a licensed
stock broker
i was a licensed at the options license
and i had a branch
manager license uh in the 1990s this was
in arizona working as a stock broker so
they're my qualifications
so the stock market is an absolute
minefield and people who go in
who don't have a clue what they're doing
will just get their legs blown off
very quickly 90 something percent of
new investors just get completely bled
dry so stay away from it if you do not
know what you are doing
stocks you know you buy let's say
tesla and it goes up 10
and you sell tesla and you make 10
profit
let's say you buy tesla it goes down 10
and you sell tesla and you lose 10
of your capital now with options
if tesla goes up 10
and you own a call option
it might go up 100 percent
or 200 depending upon how geared
that call option is if
tesla goes down 10 percent
you may lose a hundred percent of your
investment
depending upon how geared that call
option
is flip that over now to put options
put options are when you're betting it's
going to go down
tesla goes down 10 your put option may
go up
100 tesla goes down
10 i'm sorry tesla goes up 10
your put option may get be completely
wiped out you may lose 100
so the easiest way to think of options
is
as geared investments
when an underlying security moves a
fraction of a percent
an option is going to swing wildly
depending upon various factors which
include
the exercise price the exercise date
the volatility of the underlying
security and so on and so on
now if you want to capitalize on the
demise of a company
and the fall of its stock price there
are two ways to do it
you either buy put options
or you sell it short so
the short sellers on gamestop for
example
wait what is the difference between
selling it short or buying a put option
so put options are called derivative
securities
and with a put option you you can make a
very small investment
and and it's so it's geared so
tremendously that your capital can go up
hundreds of percent
very quickly or you can be wiped out
very quickly
now selling short has got nothing to do
with derivative securities
to sell short you have to pony up the
full
capital to collateralize that trade
i'll give you an example say you're a
short seller on gamestop
at five dollars and
you i want to sell short ten thousand
shares ten thousand times
five is fifty thousand
dollars depending upon your relations
with your broker
is what determines how much you must put
up to collaterize that trade
but when i back in the 90s you had to
put up at least
50 percent so i sell short 50 000
dollars worth of gamestop at five
dollars
and i put up 25 000
as collateral now
the people see that
gamestop has got a huge amount of short
selling on it
and the people think hey
this is a good opportunity for a short
squeeze
now what a short squeeze means is they
just
buy shares because
of the large short interest knowing
that if they drive the shares up
the short sellers are going to get a
margin call and then it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy when they buy
their shares back to cover their margin
call that it
it sends it even higher and even more
short sellers are triggered
to buy those shares but go back to the
guy who
put 25 000 down
game stop goes from five to six
so now he's down 10 000
so his collateral has shrunk to 15 000
[Music]
game stop goes to seven
now his collateral has shrunk to
5000 because he's down 20
000 at some point he gets a call from
his broker saying
you need to send us money if you want to
maintain this position
and that's called a minimum margin
requirement
it might be a third of the underlying
value
of the short sale but whatever it is
it's getting triggered
every single time that stock goes up
now let's say it goes to 10 and he's
down
50 grand and he's got no money left
do you know what he has to do now he has
to buy the shares back
and eat the loss and when he buys those
shirts back
what does that do sends the shirts
higher
so a guy who got wiped out at 10 he
might buy it back
send it sends it to 11 and then the guys
who are wiped out 11
they have to buy it back and they send
it to 12
and then those guys 13
and off it goes to outer space and
that's exactly what you saw with
gamestop
to the moon to the moon alice
oh my god what was your reaction when
you saw this happening
okay so i uh this is your world man this
is you're used to living this
i've seen this these things happen so
many times so it was no surprise to me
but what it what it is symptomatic of is
it is an
overheating market so we saw the corona
crash
then we saw the feds just put in the
monetary methadone
and that has lower interest rates has
just sent
everything skyrocketing and then there's
a saying in the stock market
when your barber starts recommending an
investment it's time to get the hell out
because that means there's no more
suckers left to put the money in
and that's what we've got the froth
we're at the froth
level right now